former acting ice director Tom Holman uh
Tom good morning thanks for being here
you know these numbers that bill is
talking about are just staggering I know
you've heard them you've dealt with them
but in December if you look at the
fiscal year 2021 2022 2023 look at these
numbers
235,000 in fiscal year 23 compared to
those past 3 years that is staggering
and uh how do you put you know that to
words
well there two things first Brett um
we're on a Glide path right now for
December December may be the highest
month ever recorded we're on a Glide
path to that number right now and we're
three years into Administration there's
two things that really concerned me
number one is that there are certain
sectors on the southern border now where
there isn't a single board Patrol agent
on patrol they're all processing several
sectors brought every agent into the
into the processing facility
to process which means their National
Security Mission has been put aside
that's going to mean more fog getting
across the border more bad people more
sex trafficking women and children those
that don't want to be called the second
thing is I talked to several agents last
week in in Texas they are so busy
processing and they've been in such a
push to process quickly and release
quickly they're not doing investigative
interviews they're not going through
pocket trash to find out who they're
paying how they got here they're not
doing deep deep dives into who these
people people are cuz many of these
people will lose their passports throw
their passports away before they get to
the border so the Border got to take
their word for who they are and where
they came from and this is C caused a
whole new National Security crisis so
because of a surge the job isn't being
done in this country is at Great risk
because we don't know who these people
are we don't have time to Deep dive into
an
investigation well to your point the
other graphic I wanted to put up is the
terror watch list numbers and just over
over the past 3 years there's more than
200 uh that we've seen on the terror
watch list and part of that is uh this
screening that you're talking
about yeah because you know East board
TR is trained very well how to how to
recognize when someone's lying to them
and to look at like I said back when I
was an agent look at the pocket trash
look at the information in their pockets
and try to make sense of it and and
terrorist screening database is only as
good as the data we have for instance
there are a lot of terrorists in this
world that have no record unless they've
been uh captured in a criminal
investigation or a title 3 wire tap or
unless they were encountered on the
battlefield by a soldier there's no
record of them so you know that's why we
need an investigative interview which is
not being done so there are thousands of
people entering this country that and
come from can come from countries that
sponsor Terror 171 countries and some of
these countries sponsor Terror and as
you said 227 just on the southern border
last fiscal year at the same time 432 on
the northern border
again I've said a thousand times this is
the biggest National Security failure
I've seen since
9/11 you know we're talking about almost
12,000 a day now uh and just in the past
couple weeks uh Jay Johnson former
Homeland Security secretary said if he
saw 1,000 coming across a day it was a
bad day how much Tom quickly would the
remain in Mexico policy that this
Administration kind of put aside if it
was still in place would deal with this
effectively at least
at some
point well first of all you're exactly
right Jay Johnson respect the man
greatly a thousand a day we all got
called into this office want to know
what we're doing about it but you know I
think what's happening here on the
remain of Mexico program is a game
changer in the Trump Administration and
look the the highest courts in Atlanta
said it's legal if they would put the
remaining Mex remaining Mexico program
back in tomorrow this will be a game
change of this Administration people
will still claim Asylum they just going
wait wait in Mexico for the hearing it
worked for the Trump Administration
people stopped coming people sto selling
everything they had to pay the cartels
only to come to the country and be
removed so is a game changer and and
I've seted for a year and a half put it
back in place secure the boorder and do
your job it makes sense and we've proven
it's
effective Tom hman former acting ice
director Tom we really appreciate it
Merry Christmas thanks for coming on I'm
Steve Ducey I'm Brian kilme and I'm me
airheart and click here to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis